[Music]
and while Los Angeles County says it may
extend its stay at home orders for three
months beaches in the area did open this
weekend joining me now is Dave Rubin
host of the Reuben report author of
don't burn this book father of Clyde and
a good friend of the show so Dave I know
that you've been very frustrated in
California I want you to listen to this
because I can't imagine how these
graduating seniors felt when they heard
how their drive through graduation idea
was going to be squashed watch I think
it's unfortunate that this is happening
during the pandemic because we are
asking that all graduations be virtual
only our health officer order prohibits
access state any events from happening
and even those sort of car drive-in
graduations that folks would like to
have our considerate events so for right
now there can be nothing except a
virtual graduation all right Dave Rubin
take it away
yeah well Dana look you know I'm a
simple guy and I thought that we voted
in elected officials and people in power
so that they could make complex
decisions and then explain those complex
decisions for us and that way society
could flourish but what we seem to have
a particularly bad case of unfortunately
in my state of California and really
particularly in my city of Los Angeles
is that authorities seem to think that
because they just say something that
that in and of itself makes it right or
true or worthy of being a policy and
it's like nobody explains anything and
and they seem to love these measures
that take everything to the nth degree I
mean the idea that you can't do a
drive-in graduation everyone watching
this knows how important that graduation
moment is and to be able to look at your
friends and yes see maybe it's not the
ideal situation that they're in a car
next to you but that is a little more
human than just a zillion people on a
zoom screen and the longer this goes and
this is why I'm worried about the the
August 1 situation here in California is
that the longer this
we will forget every little bit of what
it was like to be a human just two
months ago and you know when they say
August first it's like well I have a
pretty good feeling that on July 28th
that gavin newsom or eric garcetti or
one of the guys here in california is
gonna suddenly say hey you know what
guys didn't didn't flatten even more so
now we're doing this through the
election I mean that's that's really the
problem we don't have adults in the room
who are honestly explaining things to us
yeah and because the date I did not the
three months sounded like so extreme
because it's like well where is the data
telling you that in three months you
would need to have it closed down Dave
tell me like you were you loved
California but you are seriously
considering leaving the state yeah I
hate to say a Dana you know how much I
love it this is my garage I've got a
great studio here I've got a great life
here I've built my career and family
here I don't want to go but you know at
some point the rubber meets the road for
all of us that talk for a living and
it's like if I live in a place that is
so out of whack with the things that I
talk about it starts not feeling right
so I'm considering all sorts of things
and it's unfortunate but you know Abbott
and Abbott in Texas the governor Texas
obviously and DeSantis in Florida
they're doing a nice job they're not
just saying hey open up everyone run
around and nobody put masks on and do
whatever you want they're saying paint
we're trying to figure out a way to move
forward and that's the thing if you
listen to much of the media they make it
sound like oh they're opening up and
everyone can do whatever they want it's
gonna be spikes in two weeks and it's
like no they're trying to let us be free
I thought the United States had
something to do with freedom wasn't that
in one of the founding documents there
was something about freedom and
something wasn't there I think so I
think so we'll have to see I know that
you've invited okay I need to be on your
show
so I will check out and see they're both
Walter and Clyde for us unedited David
Rubin thank you if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell